vous avez probablement déjà entendu dire
de quelqu'un qu'il est car taizé on
connaît aussi des personnages de fiction
dont on a envie de dire qu'ils sont
cartésien sherlock holmes par exemple
pour sa capacité à trouver très
logiquement la solution de ces enquêtes
je trouve tout de même le dr house qui
grâce à sa grande capacité de déduction
parvient à identifier des maladies rares
et insoupçonnée ou encore tony stark
l'homme derrière le héros iron man pour
sa capacité à inventer des technologies
adaptées à ces problèmes
des fromages
une personne cartésienne ça serait donc
de prime abord une personne intelligente
et rationnelle mais est ce qu'on a
vraiment besoin d'un adjectif faisant
référence aux vieux europe des cartes
pour dire seulement ça l'intelligence et
la rationalité et bien non parce que le
sens de l'adjectif cartésien et plus
précis je suis romain et vous êtes sur
1000 et de culture générale la chaîne
qui parle meilleur de la pensée mais
sans vous prendre la tête
[Musique]
on utilise l'adjectif cartésien en
référence à la fameuse méthode de
descartes exposé dans son discours de la
méthode
cette méthode qui est à l'origine des
sciences modernes le but de dca c'était
de rompre avec la scolastique la
philosophie chrétienne du moyen âge en
fondant la recherche de la connaissance
sur des bases plus solides
sa méthode s'inspire notamment des
mathématiques afin de préserver le
raisonnement de l'erreur être cartésien
c'est donc raisonné selon cette méthode
mais qu'est ce que ça veut dire plus
précisément je vais vous l'expliquer en
trois mots être cartésien
c'est tout d'abord douté ne rien
admettre sans examen préalable et ne
jamais considérer une vérité comme
définitif le cartésien a besoin de
preuves
il est par nature plutôt sceptique
pourquoi douter à ce point parce que la
connaissance peut être détériorés par un
défaut de mémoire par l'imagination ou
encore par des préjugés transmis par
l'éducation où l'expérience le cartésien
doute parce qu'il ne veut pas prendre le
risque de se tromper
il veut mettre à l'épreuve les opinions
afin de parvenir à une vérité soly c'est
pour ça qu'il teste ses hypothèses qu'il
vérifie qu'il revérifie ses résultats
alors je ne vais pas m'étendre plus en
détail sur ce qu'est le doute cartésien
car ça sera l'objet d'une autre vidéo
j'en viens maintenant à dimension encore
plus importante de l'esprit qu'un pc
[Musique]
être cartésien
c'est surtout résonné avec ordre
mais qu'est ce que ça veut dire
raisonner avec comme ça veut dire
conduire sa pensée d'un objet au suivant
en une suite de termes de telle manière
que le suivant dépendent toujours du
précédent l'ordre est donc par essence
justifier le cartésien ne précipite pas
sa réflexion il se focalise sur l'étape
présente parce qu'il sait quelle est la
condition du passage à l'étape suivante
est ce que vous vous souvenez des
démonstrations mathématiques du collège
ou du lycée où poser des hypothèses
puisse on descendait par enchaînement
logique en utilisant des conjonctions
comme d'un bouc ou doux et bien être
cartésien
ces plaques et cette manière de
raisonner sur toute question ce n'est
pas pour rien que des cartes encourage à
faire des maths mais pour nous habituer
aux procédés de sa méthode l'ordre qui
anime l'esprit cartésien et donc
semblable à l'ordre de la réflexion
mathématique mais des cartes ne s'est
pas arrêté là
il a également donné des précisions sur
ce que devait être les étapes elle même
une réflexion rigoureuse
[Musique]
la méthode de descartes repose plus
précisément sur quatre règles alors je
ne dis pas qu'il faut les suivre à la
lettre pour mériter le qualificatif du
cartésien mais assez probable qu'on les
retrouve souvent chez un esprit
cartésien
allez voici ces quatre heures la
première c'est celle de l'évidence pour
être sûr d'avoir à faire une évidence il
faut se méfier des deux tendances de
l'esprit humain
le préjugé et la précipitation être
cartésien c'est donc se méfier des idées
toutes faites et ne pas conclure trop
vite
deuxième règle c'est celle de la
simplification en effet quand on reçoit
le données d'un problème c'est souvent
obscurs ou confus c'est pour ça que des
cartes recommande de décomposer ses
données en éléments les plus simples
possibles afin de mieux pouvoir les
examine être cartésien sedo investir du
temps afin de clarifier le problème
avant même d'en chercher la solution
la troisième règle c'est celle de
l'ordre une fois que les éléments du
problème apparaissent plus clairement il
faut les ranger du plus simple au plus
complexe
j'ai déjà d'une manière plus générale
être cartésien c'est réfléchir avec
ordre enfin la quatrième règle c'est
celle de l'exhaustivité comme l'esprit
humain fait beaucoup d'erreurs il faut
finir par mettre en doute son propre
raisonnement pour le chlore en pratique
il faut le vérifier
entièrement en passant en revue tous les
éléments afin de ne rien oublier être
cartésien
c'est donc avoir l'esprit vérificateur y
compris avec ses propres raisonnement
alors je résume les quatre règles de la
méthode cartésienne que l'on doit
pouvoir retrouver dans l'esprit
cartésien se sont l'établissement de
l'évidence la simplification l'ordre et
l'exhaustivité
[Musique]
être cartésien c'est donc douter
réfléchir avec l'ombre et peut-être même
plus précisément suivre les quatre
règles indiqué par des cartes alors être
ou ne pas être cartésien
d'un côté ça peut sembler un peu sec
comme attitude intellectuelle
on dirait qu être cartésien c'est un peu
résonné comme un programme informatique
on est loin par exemple de
l'épanouissement tirer la créativité
artistique mais de l'autre côté ça
ressemble aussi un idéal bien nécessaire
dans l'esprit humain et trompe à
l'erreur et à se laisser entraîner par
les passions je rappelle que le projet
de descartes n'était pas de tuer
l'émotion mais de dissiper les chimères
de la théologie du moyen-âge et de
guider l'homme afin qu'ils puissent
faire un meilleur usage de sa raison si
vous avez aimé la vidéo donnez lui un
pouce bleus et abonnez-vous à la chaîne
peut être prévenue de la sortie suivante
si vous voulez lire ma synthèse de la
méthode de descartes voir les gars
directement le discours de la méthode de
descartes tous les liens sont dans la
description
n'hésitez pas non plus à laisser vos
commentaires enfin si vous voulez
recevoir les dernières idées de culture
générale synthétiser no format le plus
clair possible
vous pouvez vous abonner à la newsletter
en le sang votre adresse e-mail sur le
site
je suis romain où vous étiez sur
milliers de culture générale rappelez
vous vous n'avez pas besoin de vous
prendre la tête pour vous intéresser au
meilleur de la pensée
[Musique]
m